a deadly morning on the roads and here
at this noon hour metro police are still
investigating four separate crashes
involving pedestrians three of those we
know are fatal we start near washington
and mlk a pedestrian was hit by a
vehicle on j street around 8 this
morning the victim is in critical
condition the driver initially drove
away leaving the scene but was later
caught and taken into custody now in the
far east valley off washington and mount
hood another person was hit and killed
by a car just after eight this morning
that per person pronounced dead at that
scene that driver was taken into custody
as well then we go to the west side of
town another person hit and killed this
morning and this was near rainbow and
desert inn happened around 4 the victim
pronounced dead at the scene no word on
any possible charges for the driver and
finally police are still looking for the
driver of an older white pickup truck
who left the scene of a deadly wreck
this morning flamingo and arville around
4 30. we're told the victim was hit by a
vehicle transported to umc that's where
they were pronounced dead all these
investigations are ongoing and we will
certainly have more updates both on air
and online at 8newsnow.com